I discovered This brilliant YouTube
video the other day and the title was
why Society hates creative people and
what to do about it part of the reason
was that I guess the narrator said that
most societies equate new with bad and
that scares people um also too that the
bottom line is all that matters and that
creatives are often Rebels who have
nothing left to lose and that's often
when they do their best work I was just
curious your thoughts on that yeah
creatives are Rebels that's for sure
it's it's always been that way
throughout history is just even consider
impressionist painters you know when
they uh first became active in the 1870s
18 uh 80s they were considered complete
Rebels uh they were went against the
grain of all of the classical paintings
and yet their paintings now are some of
the most of course valuable and most
popular to people throughout the world
why is that you know they were ahead of
their their time they shock people at
their time and that's what a lot of
artists do say is that their their goal
is to mix things up to be troublemakers
to be the tricksters to always have uh
Break The Rules you know most artists
are definitely uh rule Breakers they
don't often respect authority very much
obviously and so uh yes in other
cultures it's not quite as easy to do
that like in China for example you would
get stamped down if you do something too
dramatic or too revolutionary or against
Authority they would definitely uh stop
you from doing something too uh too
ahead of its time if you will or
criticizing Authority especially and
that can be the case in in many
countries in Islamic countries as well
you can't necessarily represent the
human form at all so that's why their
expression of art is uh especially in
geometric shapes in the Arab best that
you see in the Moss and that's why I
love Islamic architecture and design uh
is is because of that reason they focus
more of their creativity away from the
representation of human form into their
architectural geometric swirling
patterns Arabesque designs and colors
and tiles and it's incredibly beautiful
but very different because you can't you
can't be a free artist in in a lot of
conservative Islamic societies you will
get St down before that so so for me I
guess I'm a natural Rebel uh I
definitely have have always question
authority I was old enough to kind of go
through the edge of the uh late 60s and
so on and where people were really
expressing themselves and of course the
anti-vietnam protests and so on and so
for me it's I've always uh always
admired artists like felini and bertocci
and truo and uh so many different
European filmmakers have have really
excited me uh when I was young and of
course then on contrast David lean doing
Lawrence of Arabia now that's really uh
such a benchmark that could never be
repeated probably the best film ever
made without the aid of computers
undoubtedly I think it is so that
inspired me and uh as a filmmaker I
don't usually I don't really consider
myself an artist which is interesting I
always think of artists as being paint
ERS poets you know things like that but
uh but for me film making is I suppose I
am an artist in that sense but I find it
much so much more of a collaborative
work as you're dealing with technical
things the cameras the sound uh the crew
and and actors are involved there's so
many different elements to make a a
movie that it's hard to kind of consider
yourself the the artour or the artist
person I'm more of an organizer it feels
like when you're producing and directing
you're
organizing amazingly talented people to
come together in one amazing location uh
shoot somewhere in the world and and and
somehow again coess all of their energy
and skills to make something uh
exceptional that they can also hopefully
be very proud of as well well just on a
side note I believe you were part of a
uh film that was about Salvador Del his
DNA which I know there's a whole uh
world of you know people that do these
fakes and they're like these savants can
recreate them oh yeah yeah go ahead oh
no I just just uh so do do you ever see
any parallels between yourself and a
particular artist oh that's a good
question a parallel between uh myself
and an an artist um it just seems that
uh you know every artist definitely is
is someone very unique and individual
their own stamp so I I can't really
think of one particular artist that I
would be closest to although I I respect
Dolly tremendously he's he's a he's very
uh controversial for a lot of people
because some of his surrealistic art had
some very unpleasant looking imagery
right sometimes even people with parts
of their bodies separated from uh and so
but he was the last great Master painter
uh because he was such a disciplined uh
painter and crafts person he he just
would get down to one camel hair uh
strand of a brush sometimes to get into
the details of his paintings he could
paint incredibly large canvases as well
as smaller ones as well so he was um
quite diverse in his different uh uh
ways he expressed his art painted his
art from uh from surrealism to uh to
things that were actually even Christian
sponsored he he often would take
commissions uh and uh that's what
separated him from the uh from the
surrealist school was he got criticized
for selling out you know the dolly
dollars was a famous quote but I really
love researching Dolly and I love
researching any artist uh to make a film
about them a documentary about them
because you learn so much and and get
inspired by what uh the Collision of
inspiration they would have that goes
into each painting what they're trying
to juxtapose regarding the meaning of of
melted cheese or clocks and so on to
represent it melted cheese it was F
fascinating the uh descriptions that uh
we learned about what inspired many of
his paintings so yeah I was inspired uh
by Dolly when we were doing the
documentary and uh there's other artists
we've done work with as well that were
quite different but we also do uh had
done documentaries about topics ranging
from uh Columbus which is a very
controversial subject as well as uh
Knights Templar and their treasures and
their stories and Captain kids treasure
in Madagascar there's all kinds of
things that we we love to do
documentaries and that's been my focus
over 45 years as doing about aund some
documentaries and travel adventure shows
do you feel more alive with a camera in
your hands oh yeah absolutely
um I remember I don't remember remember
the actual person who said this but uh
it's been said the that they did a
camera person doesn't feel quite alive
until they actually are shooting that
film until they have that camera in
front of their eyes and that's they feel
like part of their life is being wasted
if they're not actually actively
producing a film and that is a very uh
interesting statement to make I mean
certainly you'd be missing a lot of life
if you felt that way because I do think
that a lot of film making actually is
the research that goes into the film
itself the pre-production the
development uh but for me my career has
been largely based behind the camera uh
I've been able to make a living mostly
by uh being behind the camera by by
filming by shooting I think I've dealt
with 20 different formats from 35mm film
to 16 to you know 1in videotape to 3/4
in film tape to Beta it's gone on and on
through the digital Realms all the way
to what it is now over these decades so
I felt that um I'm always uh out there
trying to uh to get another film made
somewhere in the world there's usually
10 different projects that
simultaneously I'm trying to run because
you never know for sure as a filmmaker
which of your next films will get
completely green lit and funded so it's
wise to have several several different
things on the different uh platters on
on uh cooking away so that when you do
finally get a green light from um a
financier an investor uh all the actors
everything comes together for your film
you can move quickly so it's wise to
have several things right there handy to
lift off the table and say okay we're
ready to do this right now we're ready
to do that several scripts ready to go
so so I'm always in
preparation uh sometimes shooting of
course and then editing so you get uh
there's never a moment when you can be
bored as a filmmaker never a second
because you're always involved with
these different steps of development of
the actual shooting the editing and then
of course the Forgotten part by a lot of
filmmakers is the marketing and
distribution
concentration because as I think you've
heard with many filmmakers that you've
interviewed uh about 60% of your work is
done when you finish your film there's
still another 40% or so uh getting the
marketing done getting distribution
accomplished to your
satisfaction and I think most filmmakers
feel uniformly they never get enough
eyes on their work they always feel like
they wish there were more people out in
the world that could see their work it's
I've I can't even remember M filmmaker
I've ever met that has been satisfied
with the the scope of uh the
distribution of their
work we talked about having many films
sort of in the fire at one time do you
see with newer filmmakers or maybe you
were possibly there yourself in the
beginning that they were precious about
one movie and they never moved on almost
like a bad relationship or a good
relationship but they just kind of kept
that was like their stamp on the world
and they never move Beyond it yeah that
is interesting as we mentioned earlier
uh filmmakers can become uh unhealthy in
their obsession with uh with one
particular
film uh because it can be to the
detriment of their uh the health of
themselves or maybe their relationships
it can destroy relationships they can uh
become obsessed with one piece of work
uh that they need to tell a story of it
either their personal story or or a
story they've developed about somebody
they know or based on a true experience
whatever it is and for me I think that
it's best not to try to become so
obsessed with one particular project
because it may not get done that's the
key thing it may not ever get produced
so you have to have I think several
things developing
simultaneously and also I think it's
very critical too not to think in terms
of uh making a masterpiece
you know your magnum opus don't think
about doing that because it's uh it can
be a huge hindrance regarding your
progress in your film making career it's
best to uh love what you're doing
there's no question you have to be in
love with your project if it's a
personal film now if it's a commercial
piece of work it's different you know
you're doing it for a client perhaps but
if it's your own personal film that
you're doing and uh I think you you have
to be in love with it but you don't the
topic but you don't want to become uh
let it own your life you don't want it
to uh obsess you completely so you uh so
you become if it doesn't happen then you
can become extremely depressed and may
not continue with your film there's a
lot of people that only make one feature
film it's a one and done situation you
know because it it took too much out of
their lives out of their souls out of of
their health out of their
finances you have to look at film making
from a business point of view as well as
art so that's where it's maybe a little
different from the other Arts a painter
can just get out a piece of canvas and
some paints it doesn't cost a lot of
money right and you can just start
working alone and and you can make
something out of that out of thin air in
a way a writer can do that as well but
usually for a filmmaker it involves so
many moving pieces
that you have to be uh a circus Master
as well as an artist and a business
person to pull it off and I've been
lucky to do that for 40 some years to
make a a life of it to make enough money
to keep doing that without doing some
other jobs which is I'm very very happy
about that and feel very fortunate in
that way you think though going back to
this video I talked about where quote
why Society hates creative people does
an artist have to really be at a point
where they have nothing left to lose and
that's their most creative or can they
actually be somewhere in the middle and
there's a healthy balance yeah yeah
that's good there's two or three
questions that are good questions right
there I think uh sometimes I I've heard
it said that uh a lot of critics or
viewers sometimes consider the the first
major work uh a filmmaker does as being
their best uh which is an interesting uh
comment uh commentary it's possible
that's true in the sense that uh it was
the the thing that the filmmaker was
most um in love with that believed in
the most thoroughly and they put the
most amount of their heart into uh is
usually their first film uh and uh so
that is there's something to be said for
that but I think it's also important to
uh if you're a young filmmaker to think
in terms of the long run of your
possible film career and not to just be
a fast 100 meter uh Dash person but
think in terms of it as a marathon or a
you know a longer race over decades how
do you want to design your life is very
critical when you're getting started
with as a filmmaker and it's sometimes
is completely overlooked usually when
you're young you just go from one
exciting project to the next without
necessarily having a big plan or a uh a
good design ahead but uh I think it's
wise to think in terms of number one
especially unless you're just doing it
for $100 or $1,000 you have to think in
terms of where is this going to be shown
uh who is your audience um why would
anybody want to ever see your film is
the first question every filmmaker needs
to ask why with all the films out there
all the different media all the
different YouTube clips why would anyone
ever want to watch your work
and that is such a hard question to ask
sometimes you might may not have an
answer right away for that so that's
when I talk to people young people about
making
films I often like to ask them
um what are you in love with what do you
what can you not resist uh researching
or doing a lot of as I said before
research should go into the making of a
film because I think again
pre-production will determine often the
success of of your movie how well it's
prepared how well it's
researched uh what what have you done to
to set the table before you have your
dinner you know it's it's very important
to think in terms of how you're going to
uh make if you're going to make a film
uh you have to decide if you want to be
I think a feature filmmaker or you can
do a documentary uh filmmaker career or
perhaps short films short firms are very
difficult though to make money with
they're often a uh a teaser for a longer
form movie you know although there are
are so many beautiful short films made
uh tremendous uh short there's Oscars
given for short films but the point is
it's very difficult to make money
commercially sell those uh usually they
have to be put together as an anthology
of short films in a way at a festival or
at a theater so I find that short films
are a great way to start if you'd like
because they can be inexp expensive to
do but if you want to design a career as
a filmmaker I think you might as well
start thinking in the long form right
away in a sense because ultimately uh
that's where you're probably going to
make enough money uh to sustain your
life as a career as as doing long long
form
stories